right now metro police continue to
search for the body of two-year-old
amari nicholson the man accused of
killing him appeared in court just a few
hours ago
the i-team's vanessa murphy first broke
the story of his arrest last night
she now has the latest on this story
from the regional justice center
a prosecutor says terrell rhodes
admitted to abusing and
killing two-year-old amari nicholson
judge joe bonaventure ordered him to be
held without bail
[Music]
are you mr rhodes terrell rhodes nodding
and then listening to the allegations
against him
he faces a murder charge of the
defendant live for approximately one
week
regarding covering up the murder that
nominated against this child
metro police say rhodes confessed to
hitting omari numerous times which
caused his death on may 5th
and then hid the child's body according
to the clark county district attorney's
office
evidence includes blood on a wall and
soiled child's clothing
amari was first reported missing from
the emerald suites at paradise and twain
on may 5th police and search teams tried
to find the boy
his mother taylor nicholson along with
rhodes who is her boyfriend
talked with eight news nails joe moller
on may 7.
rhodes was watching amari while his
mother was out of town
he claimed a woman calling herself an
aunt showed up to take the child
what's really sickening is that people
is
making assumptions thinking that i have
something to do with it that
i have heard
manipulated in some way which
that sticking into me also because
he loves us we never do nothing like
that to him
the i-team has requested an interview
with terrell rhodes while he's
in jail we are waiting to hear back
reporting in downtown las vegas vanessa
murphy
8 news now